on top of everything else the
coronavirus continues to be at pandemic
levels there are increases in numbers
throughout the country there are plenty
of people who either choose to
consciously ignore it or they haven't
bothered to stop and notice it's raising
questions again about the nfl's 2020
season jed york the 49ers ceo told
jennifer lee chan of nbc sports bay area
there will be a season in some way shape
or form after seeing the progress of
reopening i am confident in that i know
our players and staff are ready and
excited to get things rolling yeah i've
seen some of the progress of reopening
some of the photographs are stunning and
you know
it's
when when you see a photo of a crowded
nightclub
the first thing that some people say is
well nobody said any of this during the
protest well the protests were an
organic
life form they were something that
happened in reaction to something that
shouldn't have happened it's not like
people are saying hey i'm gonna go out
and have a good time here they were
going out to do something they thought
they were compelled to do that overcame
their fears of the chronovirus and most
of the people i saw protesting had masks
on when i see photos of these jam
nightclubs i don't see a single freaking
mask in there chris so these two things
are not the same by any means
no they're they're definitely not uh you
know we've still got things to work out
in society and of course in sports i
mean it's where
we're still in a tough spot here
and as much as i thought like oh i'm
optimistic the nfl is going to play and
everything like that i'm a little scared
right now just because i don't know
i still don't know where we stand mike
you know first off yes society is still
in some some areas kind of taking this
lightly
so that's not going to help things two
months from now you know this is we're
seeing cases rise and a lot of the
states that have you know taken away the
stay-at-home orders and other things
like that
cases are going through the roof again
but then also
you know again just the progress with
players in the nfl and things like that
i'm scared of where it's at mike i mean
we're seeing college football some of
these schools are getting back together
having workouts whatever it may be and
you're seeing that players are testing
positive right away
and i just i just don't know where the
nfl is at this point and that's of
course we know society is in a weird
spot but
i'm specifically talking about nfl here
and it just the society is kind of a
microcosm to say i don't know where this
could go and is it going to be realistic
to think we can play a full season of
games here
yeah the university of houston's
football program under dana holgerson
shut down voluntary workouts after six
of the athletes tested positive for
covet 19. so
it's it's a reality as you bring people
together and put them in close quarters
and here's the problem
last week we get the memo from the nfl
outlining detailed protocols for what
will happen inside of a facility and
everyone must be six feet apart and it
has to be that way at the stadium and
there is restricted access areas and
there's tier one tier two tier three
individuals who may or may not have
access and it's all very detailed and
then we find out the nfl players
association hasn't agreed to any of this
so
how do we get the union in the league on
the same page on such important matters
and then you've got john harbaugh the
ravens coach last thursday saying it's
humanly impossible to comply with these
requirements and he's concerned that if
his team complies with them somebody out
there's not and they're going to get a
competitive advantage because they're
not spending time complying and
otherwise using that time to get ready
for the next game that's going to be the
problem there's going to need to be an
enforcement mechanism over and above the
actual protocol that ensures that
everyone complies otherwise everyone's
eventually going to break the rules once
they hear the patriots are doing this
and this team is doing that and this
team is doing that so we're not going to
follow the rules and then the next thing
you know you're going to have too many
guys who test positive to have football
games so they need and and and again and
let me just be clear on this for anyone
out there who may doubt my motive i want
there to be football season and part of
their being football season is ensuring
that the people who are in charge are
asking all the right questions answering
all the right questions anticipating all
the hurdles before the hurdles are right
in front of them and they have to try to
jump over them and i have yet to get the
feeling
of confidence
necessary to believe that they've got it
all figured out i feel like there's a
lot of make it up as we go
and we'll deal with it when it comes and
we'll cross our fingers and hope for the
best that's not going to fly chris it
needs to be more no way it needs to be
more planned out and there needs to be
more agreement between the league and
the union and you better get the coaches
on board too you know they don't have
any problem sending out memos telling
teams to shut up about this and shut up
about that they should send out memos
telling the coaches to shut up too but
i'm kind of glad that harbaugh said what
he said because it proves my point we we
have to get to a point where we feel
good about about whatever is planned or
not planned for the 2020 season and we
want it to land we want it to happen
well it's not concise yet it's it's not
real enough you know and of course just
just because we have somewhat of a good
plan written down on paper doesn't mean
you know there's gonna be plans are
gonna be you know thrown for a loop and
we're gonna get thrown a curveball by by
you know by unforeseen circumstances
things like that
you know again i'm gonna go back to this
one more time there's two things because
it's i've been thinking about it a lot
of course i won football too i mean it's
my favorite thing to do is watch a
football game let alone my job depends
on it so of course me and mike want
football but like
okay
you know i'm gonna go back to like
because i saw ohio state did it this
weekend like signing a waiver about the
corona virus right
can can we get again i'm gonna go back
to that can we get the nfl players and
the nfl together and have a vote and
just see who's willing to sign the
waiver and go okay i'm i'm willing to
play even if coronavirus is in the in
the locker room whatever it may be mike
i know you and i also texted this
weekend too is it a crazy idea to have
like
i don't know i'm just throwing this out
there because i know me as a 27 year old
nfl football player would certainly be
down for this is it crazy to get like
the nfl players in into camp two three
weeks early expose them to the virus get
them antibodies
put them in you know seclusion don't let
them see anybody for that two or three
weeks and then we can go back and just
go to football and not have to worry
about anything i mean i'm just
brainstorming i don't know
but these are things that like to what
you're saying you know there's a lot of
things planned out but it doesn't seem
like the hard-line factors are quite
planned out yet and to think that
nobody's not going to get coronavirus
and we're going to escape through this
by great protocol and all that i just
find that hard to believe at some point
somebody's going to get it and what are
we going to do like cancel certain parts
of the season because five people got it
because 10 people got it because that
one half of a team has it i don't know
that to me doesn't make sense either so
you know i i just yeah i feel like the
conversation is lagging here a little
bit between the players and the nfl at
this moment
the example that you set out about
bringing teams in two weeks early and
exposing them all that that's an extreme
and extreme representation of what we
were discussing here's what i want to
let everyone know
most days we do a segment called pftot
after the live show ends on nbcsn that's
going to be the topic for today i i have
some thoughts on that that aren't nearly
as radical as bringing the entire team
in and exposing them to the virus
two weeks before you start training camp
but i i i it's a more subtle and it's
more nuanced and it's more
individualized view
on getting the antibodies in your system
before you get to a point where you may
get shut down for two weeks during a key
stretch of the season but that's coming
up later today on pftot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports